[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con este 4 de
agosto de 2021 se cumple un año de la
explosión que devastó el puerto de
beirut la capital de líbano la tragedia
dejó más de 200 muertos 6 mil 500
heridos 300.000 desplazados e
incontables daños materiales además
profundizó la crisis del país en donde
todavía no se ha podido formar un nuevo
gobierno nos acompaña a dida saab ella
es profesora en letras y testigos de
esta explosión gracias por acompañarnos
profesora saab usted usted estaba en
beirut en aquella jornada trágica para
el país cuéntenos un poco cómo lo vivió
y qué recuerda de ese día
buenas tardes desde aquí desde beirut
recuerdo ese día haber estado en el
balcón precisamente por ser una época
bastante calurosa tuvimos la ventaja de
tener todas las ventanas abiertas y
luego yo en un último piso el cual sus
balcones no están fechados eso impidió
que tuviéramos los años que tuvieron el
resto de los departamentos de este
edificio los edificios de al lado pero
recuerdo haber visto el humo y haber
escuchado como explosión de javier o
fuegos artificiales o algo que contenga
pólvora y había sido muy repetitivo esto
implica que ya había una señal de que si
había un material tan peligroso cerca de
otro material más peligroso aún había
tiempo de sacar a la gente y había
tiempo de no enviar a quienes enviaron a
supuestamente apagar el incendio de
repente vino la primera explosión está
con solamente un poco de humo gris y
luego la última que es la que todos han
visto en los medios y que todavía
llevamos
a nuestra tristeza y nuestra falta de
respuesta por parte de los responsables
que son por supuesto todos los que están
en el gobierno
dida en su momento la onu calculó que 7
de cada 10 hogares afectados sólo
pidieron una ayuda básica tras esta
explosión en su caso como impacto como
impacto la detonación en en su casa en
su vivienda sí bueno como le digo
afortunadamente en mi balcón no es
techado en todos los departamentos
no solamente tuvieron los cristales
rotos los de afuera sino incluso los de
adentro
pasaron por aquí nuestra zona no fue la
primera zona que recibió el impacto
nuestra zona es la que llamaron de daños
reportados
si pasaron por aquí personas del
gobierno a ver cuáles habían sido los
daños en algunos casos o mandaron alguna
cosa por reparar o dieron algo de dinero
en efectivo pero por supuesto no es lo
mismo que las zonas que estaban al
principio cerca del acuerdo estas es de
estos hogares el gobierno no tuvo ningún
carro no no se hizo cargo de nada
trató de hacerlo pero pues con un
gobierno enredado que nos llevó a esta
tragedia no creo que tengan la solución
en la mano como para empezar con una
reconstrucción lo que se ha podido
reconstruir ha sido a través de
iniciativa privada organizaciones no
gubernamentales pero muchas casas
no solamente tuvieron daño en un cristal
o en una madera tuvieron daños en su
estructura estas son las que más han
tardado y siguen igual un poco de
escombros pensión colocan dobla agua
pero todavía en la descripción si vida
le pregunto qué cambio en el país desde
aquel día no sólo a nivel político sino
también económico social y por supuesto
emocionalmente cómo se siente beirut
cómo se respira
beirut se siente enojada con una gran
con grandes ansias de pedir cuentas
y aquí nos han mantenido divididos o en
partidos políticos o en grupos
religiosos o en grupos en todas las
variedades que te gusten pensar y luego
nos dimos cuenta de que es la mejor
forma que ha tenido el gobierno como
para que no nos unamos lamentablemente
no nos escucharon cuando pasó cuando
sucedió la revolución del 2019 en la que
ya todo el pueblo había dicho pues somos
víctimas de una cantidad de acuerdos que
se están haciendo a nuestras espaldas
viene la explosión de beirut nos hemos
vuelto completamente incrédulos y con
todas las ganas del mundo que son las
que vamos a manifestar hoy y que no
hemos dejado de manifestar de pedir
cuentas a quienes nos pidieron apoyo y
que ha sido completamente todo el
gobierno hay una desolación total hay
una tristeza social pero la herida
abierta no se ha empezado a sanar
mientras no haya justicia y no levante
la inmunidad no no vamos a hacer que
nuestra activa así es la salud o el
abrazo es aquí debuta hasta virus
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y gracias también ustedes
[Música]